今日はこれ何だと思いますか
書いてあるじゃねーかこれはパンパンでしてパソコン
実は僕恥ずかしながら編集はずっとノートパソコン1台でしてますねこちらの
macbook air ですね
スペックもそんな高くないんですかソ放送で詳しくないんですけど
macbook air the 限界がきたプトってよく止まったりしたんで
増税前にちゃんとしたパス本買わなきゃ区のホームページ超
パソコンを買いましたよパソコンでて詳しくないんでパソコンが j の形からしたら
もうここら辺はちょっとご了承願いますよ
まあ俺本当にでパソコンが使ったことないんで正直怖いんしてはけれども
ぞスパーンドスパラつついいとこで買いましたパソコン屋さんです
旅行じゃないですけどデレってぱ蕎麦屋さんで買いたかったんですけど
増税前に買ったで姉さんすごい発注が発注てか出れさんすごい注文が多かったらしくて
口コミで全然来ないって言ってる人も多かったんで諦めて
ほど縛らにしました
それが始まってた
というわけでさっそく開けていきましょうパソコンたんでちょっと慎重に取り扱って
いこうと思います
僕は f
鉄鋼受けロード入ってるぞ実はこのパソコンなんですけど
ペット名前がなんだかわかんないです南庭ためにパソコンなんだろうそれをまず最初に
言わなきゃ以前気がしてきた
こちら前ととスパーさんのレイトレック vhx
windows 8.1版でございます多分
いいパスこんなだと思います付属はへ
でなにこれ
を
やっぱなんかなんすとかなんかまーすとかマジとか
まーすとが付いてますよ怖いなぁ
おおおおおお
格好良い
こんな感じです
やべん
ブラもなんか
おざぶ立っています
スマでちょっと何もわかんない存在ん
もう中身がすごい
中身が何か凄いです
これがきっとパソコンのすごい人が頑張って作ってくれたんでしょ
ありがとうございます
でなんでデスクトップのパソコンを買おうと思ったかって言ったらかっこいいからなん
ですよ
真実がやっぱ赤黒こんなでかいですくれ話
しっかりドゼット構えていこうパソコンしたいなって思って
ですちょっと増税前に買ったっちゅう感じです
a single cd が4万円を廃止します全部英語で書いてるじゃん
みんなん
読めるけど歩い像桜
ません
やっぱ下に置きますね
馬込が分ん
おん
ん
を
自ら放った
えっ
いやこれだあのねぇよちょっと気持ちが高まりすぎて画面が映りませんが
ん
まあいいでしょう画面が映らないくらい問題ないです
ドスパランってこうなんかやっぱりされたんですけど
僕の youtube の知り合いからの勧めでは凄い性能有りと言われたのでぜひ
レイトレックシリーズ
あの増税後なんで高いかもしれないんですけど
です
こういうパ側欲しいなって思ったらこちらぜひ感じてみてはいかがでしょうか
今月の羽根がないですはじめ車窓でしたじゃあ
ん